all right this is from axios it says
nearly a quarter of college students who
wouldn't be friends
uh rather nearly quarter of college
students wouldn't be friends with
someone who voted for the other
presidential candidate with democrats
far more likely to dismiss people than
republicans
according to the new generation lab
axios polling
says uh by the numbers five percent of
republicans said they wouldn't be
friends with somebody from the opposite
party compared to 37 percent of
democrats
71 percent of democrats wouldn't go on a
date with someone with opposing views
versus 31 percent of republicans
and 30 percent of democrats and 7
republicans wouldn't work with someone
or for someone who voted differently
from them now
i've seen these results
uh you know being being posted
especially by people on the right by
conservatives
and uh
very sort of proud of themselves and and
saying see we're we're we're the
open-minded ones we'll we'll date
someone it's the democrats who aren't
open-minded
i actually think the democrats have the
right idea here
i think i think they're right
now
be friends with someone who votes
differently from you that's that's one
thing we have to talk about what we even
mean by friends like i'm talking a
friendly acquaintance
even that now if i want to have a real
uh deep meaningful friendship with
someone
that is going to be very difficult
if they're on the left
because we just have there's really
nothing in common
it doesn't mean you can't be a friendly
acquaintance with someone but if you
want to be a if there's a chance for a
real bond in a real friendship even that
is going to be pretty difficult
but dating someone i think democrats
they're exactly right here
and if you're a republican you should be
happy that most democrats have this view
because they're going to save you
especially if you're single and you're
on the dating scene
the fact that you know if you're if
you're a single man on the dating scene
the fact that according to the poll most
democrat women
will not date you that is that is a good
thing
that's for your own good they're saving
you from themselves just let them do it
but especially when it comes to a
romantic relationship dating someone it
just doesn't work because this goes
beyond this is not just who you vote for
it's
[Music]
we're differentiating by republican and
democrat right now but that's not really
the point
um
the ideological lines
are so deep now
and the gap between the two sides is so
vast
that again it's one thing to be a
friendly acquaintance with someone but
to have a romantic relationship with
somebody
who's on the other side of that vast
cavernous
divide
how is it even possible
you have to have some basic
fundamental things in common you have to
know that has to get down to your your
values
as a human being what do you care most
about most deeply about
opposites attract yes but that
there we're talking about
personality
temperament
uh maybe hobbies and interests and that
kind of thing
my wife has a very different personality
for me very different like it could not
be diametrically
opposite a personality for me
and yet we've been married happily for
uh almost 11 years and that's because
personality is one thing and that keeps
things interesting when you're dating
someone you're with someone who's a
different personality i wouldn't want to
i cannot imagine spending every day
in a house with someone with the same
personality as me that would be a
nightmare
feel sorry for my wife
um
so that's okay that's good
but underneath that you have to have
your you have to have the same values
and priorities in life
because if you don't have those that's
when everything falls apart very quickly
in a relationship
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content
you